hey so last week I mentioned to you that
Megan Kelly on her NBC daytime show was
reminiscing about the times when it was
okay to wear blackface when you were a
white person this is her horribly rated
daytime show just as a reminder here's
the segment in question which we looked
at last week still be able to dress like
a [ __ ] you do get in trouble if you are
a white person who puts on black babies
or a black person who puts on white face
for Halloween like back when I was a kid
that was okay as long as you were
dressing up as like that's character if
somebody feels like something is
offensive to them then you should say it
and that's fair game she ended up
apologizing later that same day and then
we learned that megan kelly is not going
to be back it's unclear what's going to
happen with her occasional Sunday
evening sort of news magazine style show
or interview show it's unclear whether
she'll still be covering the elections
in a couple of weeks on NBC News as she
was scheduled to do but she is not going
to be returning to her daytime show here
is the most important element of this
story do not believe for a second that
this is a political correctness firing
because of the blackface thing NBC News
has been waiting to end this show to
kill this show for a very long time it's
a terrible show it gets bad ratings the
only time it would ever make news was
when megyn kelly or someone else stepped
in it on the program now can we
criticize NBC News for not having the
testicular fortitude to just fire her
before they had something like the
blackface thing 2.2 yes in fact there's
probably a financial reason this was
sort of a calculation by NBC News based
on how her contract may have been
written where they said you know if we
get rid of her because of these comments
supposedly we may be able to avoid
paying out some more significant
fraction of her contract than we
otherwise would if we just say the
ratings are bad and we're gonna get rid
of you so from NBC's perspective I don't
actually think that it's about blackface
at all now if we want to talk about
blackface blackface has a hugely
disturbing past
it's a dumb comment but we can disagree
about whether that comment in and of
itself would warrant a firing so like
Genki ogre from TYT for example made a
video where he said it was wrong for her
to be fired period because of the
blackface comments some people loved it
and they said jank is breaking through
sort of partisan expectations on this
issue and he's saying something that
makes sense others said hold on a second
the blackface comments do deserve firing
but I'm not on either of those sides
what I'm telling you is she wasn't fired
for the blackface comments whether by
definition blackface is racist or it
should be on the list of statements or
actions which would warrant a firing we
can debate that I don't really care to
right now I am NOT a defender of huge
media conglomerates taking advantage of
employees I don't like blackface I don't
like megyn kelly
but this wasn't about blackface this was
about megyn kelly hosting a failing show
this was about NBC News knowing that
waiting trying to figure out sitting in
boardrooms thinking about how can we get
rid of megyn kelly and it will likely
work out pretty well for them she was a
bomb waiting to go off
they wanted the show out and now they
can claim it's because of blackface even
though the reality is it's a terrible
show the really dumb move that was made
his NBC shouldn't have lured her away
from Fox News to begin with Fox News and
their audience was the place where she
could successfully kowtow and draw an
audience NBC News is just not the place
for her so I would say NBC should
probably actually fire whoever made the
decision to lure her away from Fox News
in the first place that's really who we
need to look at punishing here if you
are NBC